god do i love these two fat  [Music]  they are my two favorite people i can't  believe i met them in real life  we had a was the dinner good  oh dude  dude dinner was great thank you i spent  six hundred dollars  was it really it was postmates  do you know if you spend 600 on post  mates  you go on a list like i'm gonna get  denied end of life care  we're kidding when you're on the road is  it hard to not you know eat like  wildebeests like wild boar  just tearing apart a tourist that you  found late on a beach at night is that  the way because i see the way you  descend on an applebee's we usually eat  like once a day just so we don't have to  eat that's what you said earlier you eat  once a day that's fascinating to me yep  you don't have time to eat right now  that one time a day  [Laughter]  10 15 000 calories  do you make it cow